ça va ouais ça va bon merci de nous
accueillir dans le petit Bayon ouais
pour parler de notre sujet notre combat
commun le logement accès au logement
pour tous là entre 2015 et 2020 il y a
plusieurs dizaines de logements rien que
dans cette rue qui sont devenus des rbnb
donc permanent ce 3è étage là il y avait
un couple de jeunes travailleurs qui
payit un loyer de 500 € comme ça la
propriétaire les a fait dégager et a
transformé ça en BNB qui se louait du
coup à autour de 100 € la
[Musique]
nuit bonjour Inaki et Chanis député des
Pyrenées atlantiqu on est ici à Bayon au
Pays-Basque pour parler de la crise du
logement qui frappe ce territoire comme
les Vallis beranaises et comme beaucoup
d'autres territoires en France du fait
de la spéculation immobilière de la
montée des taux d'intérêt de la
multiplication des meublés de tourisme
et avec des vraies difficultés pour les
habitants de se loger là où ils vivent
et là où ils travaillent donc nous
devons agir en tant que parlementaire
Perre à chacun de trouver un
to sur la Côte Basque au début de
l'automne les vacanciers sont partis il
reste ceux qui vivent ici toute l'année
mais dans cette région touristique où
l'économie est florissante les habitant
ont de plus en plus de mal à se loger le
député socialisteaki et Chan retrouve
cette
fois le fondateur de l'association Alda
qui a les locir
[Musique]
bon alors qu'est-ce qui se passe ici bon
là on va aller visiter monsieur
fabriceupon qui en fait est locataire
depuis 20 ans ici a eu un congé pour
vente donc il doit dégager allez on y va
plusieurs fois par mois l'association
est sollicitée par des habitants menacés
d'expulsion bonjour merci de nous
recevoir à 60 ans Fabrice doit se
préparer à quitter son
quartier par donc si vous pouvez nous
expliquer un petit peu ce qui se passe
pour vous bah ce qui se passe c'est que
voilà ça fait 18 ans que je vis dans
dans ce studio et que j'ai appris en
juin 2022 que ma propriétaire décidait
de vendre et qu'il fallait que je parte
et est-ce que vous avez une solution de
relogement actuellement non et parce que
les loyers sont trop chers c'est trop
cher j'ai 1045 € de revenu 90 €
deallocation logement et là je paye 430
€ voilà c'est impossible de retrouver au
même prix non c'est impossible vous avez
fait une demand de logement social alors
j'ai fait une demande de logement social
en bah en juin en juin 2022 hein ou tout
de suite ouais tout de suite jeis passé
en commission en novembre 2022 et bon
j'étais j'ai pas été retenu ce n'est pas
acceptable aujourd'hui en 2023 que
quelqu'un puisse être sorti de son
logement sans raison valable et qu'on ne
lui propose pas d'autres solutions il y
aurait suffisamment de logements sociaux
il y aurait un parc privé avec des prix
abordables on pourourait l'entendre mais
aujourd'hui la situation est telle que
ce n'est plus acceptable de faire la
spéculation parce que la propriétaire va
le vendre bien évidemment plus cher en
le vendant vide tous crent surtout que
ce studio ne devienne un appartement
touristique suffit de voir à mon agence
sur vitrine c'est que des locations de
vacances il y a quelques mois ils
avaient une annonce à l'année sur
l'étage je suis tout seul à
l'année résion secondaire résion
secondaire résent secondaire
Airbnb petit à petit n V sont grignotés
par les résiden secondaires ici à biitz
il y a plus de logements que d'habitants
et pourtant plus personne arrive à se
loger au paysbasqu l'histoire de Fabrice
est loin d'être
isolée avec l'arrivée des plateformes de
location en ligne il y a de moins en
moins de logements disponibles pour les
locaux ce phénomène a changé la
physionomie du quartier historique de
Bayon ça c'est le drapeau com de plus en
plus habitant pour demander le droit à
vivre et se loger au
pays il y a quelques mois dans cette
zone chev et son association ont squatté
un appartement loué via Airbnb pour
dénoncer la
spéculation le député bien conscient du
problème voit monter l'exaspération des
habitants quand j'ai pour vendre scène
de vie ordinaire au Pays Basque ici 2/
des nouvelles résidences secondaires
sont d'ancienne résidence principale je
crois que le message est clair ou cette
immense fresque a été peinte par un
collectif d'association qui viennent
d'obtenir une première victoire les
villes de la côte basque impose
désormais un système de
compensation chaque propriétaire qui met
en location un appartement de tourisme
doit obligatoirement en mettre un second
en location à l'année cette nouvelle
réglementation est très contraignante
mais il est encore trop tôt pour savoir
si elle enraye vraiment la spéculation
favorable à ce système
le député sait aussi qu'il n'y a pas de
mesure magique alors le socialiste a
rédigé une proposition de loi avec des
collègues renaissance pour défendre
d'autres
solutions la première des choses c'est
de revoir la fiscalité aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui loue en meublé de tourisme
à 71 % d'abattement sur ses revenus
alors que quelqu'un qui loue en longue
durée de façon pérenne il a 30 %. nous
ce qu'on propose c'est de à minima
remettre à égalité les taux d'imposition
et de les baisser à 30 % si ce n'est
d'augmenter l'abattement fiscal sur la
longue durée pour encourager les
propriétaires parce qu'on est dans une
telle situation de crise qu'il faut
faire revenir du logement sur le longue
durée en juin 2023 sa proposition de loi
transpartisane a été déprogrammée de
l'agenda de l'Assemblée nationale à la
dernière minute car le gouvernement n'en
voulait pas les plateformes non
plus à cause de la pénurie de logement
la tension est vive entre une partie des
habitants et des élus
et de l'autre les propriétaires
desmeublés de tourisme le nouveau
système de compensation accentue encore
le conflit une association de
propriétaires s'est lancé dans une
longue bataille juridique pour le faire
annuler Carla en fait partie en colère
elle ne veut pas rencontrer le député
elle accepte de nous parler à condition
de rester
anonyme on a peur peut-être que
j'exagère je ne sais pas mais on a peur
de représaill pense que vous avez vu ce
qui s'est passé sur beaucoup d'agences
immobilières où il y a des tags
aujourd'hui c'est les tags demain c'est
des bonbes on voudrait pas se retrouver
notre appartement tagué ou squatter ou
voilà Carla vit dans l'intérieur du pays
basque en 2015 elle a acheté ce de
pièces près de l'océan qu'elle loue 5
mois par an via les plateformes en ligne
avec les nouvelles règles qui
s'appliquent aussi aux actuels
propriétaires elle ne pourra bientôt
plus le faire on a économisé pour avoir
tout ça on on s'est sacrifié et
maintenant qu'on que l'on est bien on a
impression de d'avoir pris une claque
dans la figure franchement on ne pensait
à aucun moment qu'on allait nous
interdire de faire ce que l'on veut de
notre résidence secondaire sachant qu'on
ne leur mettra pas en vente et on ne
fera pas de location à l'année donc on
nous prive de notre liberté de choix sur
cet
appartement on voudrait pas devenir les
les bouquets émissaire du manque de
logement on comprend pas pourquoi les
communes n'ont pas fait le nécessaire
depuis 20 ans à faire de la
construction loin de l'Atlantique dans
l'intérieur des terres le manque de
logement est aussi un problème même dans
les zones les plus reculées du
béarne dans la circonscription du député
la vallée d'ASP a longtemps perdue des
habitants désormais elle en gagne pour
les nouveaux arrivants ce loger relève
du parcours du combattant nous
retrouvons Inaki et chanise qui rend
visite à grégoryi depuis des mois ce
quin génner vit dans un
[Musique]
git voilà on met tout en entendant quoi
vous stockz votre vie c'est ça un peu ça
on a monté notre linge et tout le reste
on a nos meubles ici quoi nos souvenirs
nos tableaux nos photos tout ce qui
était sensé être temporaire ça dure un
peu plus ça fait une petite année là
ouais
à l'étage la décoration est figée dans
les années 70 Grégory et sa famille
n'ont rien touché juste ajouter quelques
photos pour personnaliser l'endroit ils
veulent acheter leur propr maison mais
il n'y a quasiment rien à vendre et les
prix sont
exorbit o est-ce que vous en êtes on a
déj éches on va dire parce que ça été
vendu pour une résidence secondaireme
DOM et un autre parce qu'on est quand
même dans une région où c'est protégé et
on peut pas rénover les maisons comme on
voudrait quoi ça fait 12 ans qu'on vient
ici quoi et puis moi je suis parapenti
c'est quandême un gros secteur
d'activité ici j'ai racheté une société
dans le parapente donc c'est vraiment
important d'être établi ici quoi enfin
moi je suis surpris il y a des prix
c'est comme à Bordeaux quoi sur la
valallé d'ASP on a quantifié entre une
augmentation de 30 à 40 % du prix du
mètre carré depuis depuis le covid et
encore nous on une situation enfin on a
des revenus on a on a vendu notre maison
donc on a un petit pcul quoi les banques
vont nous suivre je la place des jeunes
dans la vallée ça doit pas être facile
quoi on a aujourd'hui des enfants de la
vallée des jeunes de la vallée de mon
âge qui ne peuvent pas qui ne peuvent
pas venir ici et c'est un déchirement
énorme al c'est pas du communitarisme
mais c'est dire je viens d'un territoire
dans lequel je peux plus habiter une
bonne fin de journée à vous merci au
revoir comme sur le littoral le problème
viendrait des résidences secondaires qui
font concurrence au logement permanent à
8 km du git le village d'acous le
village dans lequel grégoryi et sa
famille voudrai poser définitivement
leur valises iaki et chaniz à
rendez-vous avec le maire pour une
visite
[Musique]
guidée on va faire un petit tour petit
tour dans le village ouais ça marche ok
allez alors on y va
oui donc notre notre problème à nous
effectivement c'est les résidences
secondaires c'est 50 % à peu près de la
commune hein à l'image de la Allemage de
la vallée résidence secondaire résidence
familiale fermée ça aussi hein c'est
ouvert mais c'est une résidence
secondaire
ça aussi ça aussi
après pour le maire d'acous trouver des
maisons pour ceux qui veulent vivre ici
toute l'année est un combat quotidien et
n'hésite pas s'il le faut à faire
l'intermédiaire par exemple ces deux
maisons là que tu vois ici là celle-ci
qui est au premier plan et l'autre qui
est derrière sont devenus des résidences
principales depuis quelques mois
pourquoi parce qu'on a négocié de
manière à ce qu'il fasse des prix
raisonnables et du coup on a fixé deux
familles en résidence principale tuas
combien d'habitants à l'année 470
habitants et l'été tu montes on doit
monter un millier entre toutes les
maisons qui sont ouvertes les campings
et cetera on doit monter à un millier
d'habitants pour juguler les prix le
député socialiste veut changer la loi et
là encore son levier ce sont les impôts
la volonté qu'on a c'est de donner des
outils pratiques aux communes et
notamment aux petites communes pour
pouvoir agir justement en faveur de
l'habitat permanent donnez-moi un
exemple ben concrètement ça veut dire
qu'on va taxer de façon plus forte
quelqu'un qui va avoir acheté une
résidence secondaire qui va la garder 2
ans juste dans l'état d'esprit de faire
une plusvalue derrière de faire un coup
de peinture ou de creuser une piscine et
qui va la vendre 100000 € de plus de ou
3 ans plus tard le maire tient aussi à
montrer aux députés une des maisons à
vendre dans le
villagei pour les touristes donc on
arrive devant la maison Camille qui est
une très belle maison une ancienne
maison familiale qui est en vente il y a
300 m² de surface habitable avec un
grand jardin derrière et il y aurait la
possibilité de faire TR trois logements
quasiment dedans elle est à vente à 120
130000 € mais c'est un prix négociable
et il y a au moins pour 300000 € de
travaux à faire minimum si on veut la
rendre si on veut faire trois
appartements indépendants on a le droit
de préemption c'est-à-dire que si
vraiment je sentais que cette maison va
partir en résidence secondaire ou en
Airbnb à ce moment-là j'aurai la
possibilité de me porter à cur au prix
de finement d'achat c'estàdire 120000 €
mais nous commune on aura pas les moyens
derrière d'investir 300000 ou 400000 €
pour faire des appartements si les
maires ont déjà le droit d'augmenter la
taxe d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires le député voudrait en
relever le
plafond ça ne les poussera pas forcément
à remettre à revendre leur biens ou à
les mettre à la location longue durée
mais ça les fera participer à l'effort
général et ça permettra aussi à la
collectivité de ramasser cet argent et
de réinvestir dans des projets à
voocation de longue durée comme ça peut
le cas
ici un combat en cours pour inignaki et
chanise alors que la crise du logement
s'accentue il ne désespère pas d'arriver
à convaincre les autres députés et le
gouvernement d'adopter ses
[Musique]
propositions